jaco is a minimal amount of competent
defensive ability
self-defense essentially the most
overlooked essential stabilizer of
young male psyche
so this question this actually this
actually came across the interwebs as
a as a statement an opinion
and i i kind of rephrased it just a
little bit to make it into a question
but it actually came across someone was
saying look
he believes this person believes that
the knowing how to fight
you know competent defensively defensive
ability i call that knowing how to fight
is and he thinks it's the most essential
stabilizer of a young male psyche
i agree with this statement i think that
yeah i completely agreed i think that
learning how to fight and knowing how to
fight
gives you real
confidence and security not just in the
form of being secure but as
a in in opposition to insecurity
right because when you know how to fight
all of a sudden you don't have anything
to prove anymore yeah and we
this changes so i you know i wish i
would have learned how to fight and i'm
watching we fought all the time when i
was a kid
we fought we didn't know how to fight so
what do we have to do prove that we knew
how to fight
if we actually knew how to fight we
wouldn't have to prove that all the time
so i absolutely agree with this and
that's why i'm constantly trying to get
people
uh to get into jiu jitsu it's you know
get your kids in
get your 13 year old boy your 10 year
old boy
get him into jiu jitsu your girl too i
mean your girl too because your girl is
going gonna use it for defense
um girls don't have the
constant tension of fighting that guys
have it is
part of who we are when i shake
someone's hand
i don't care what kind of mood i'm in i
am thinking about taking them down
i am thinking about what i'm going to do
during a fight it doesn't matter if i'm
meeting
santa claus i'm thinking about doing a
double leg i'm thinking about what
what his weight is does he have
cauliflower here that's what i'm doing
and guys do that guys do that
and it's real and i mean especially in
the environment i grew up in the single
teams i mean
everybody's got that constant
like test between you they evaluate it's
the evaluation
so if you don't know how to fight
there's only one way to figure out
where you are and that is to fight
and so you end up doing stupid things
stupid things
to prove your your manhood and i hate to
use that word but you end up doing
stupid things to prove your manhood
so my recommendation um is well i
totally agree with this statement i
think it is a huge stabilizer
of of your personality
and your psyche as a man so teach
get those kids to learn jiu jitsu
they're gonna understand the other thing
is you understand
violence you respect it because you know
you got choked out
you know it's happened you know that is
a horrible feeling
it's a horrible feeling when another
human being
can control you a hundred percent you
know what
physically it doesn't matter how smart
you are anymore
i'm sorry it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how smart you
are anymore
when you are getting completely
physically dominated by someone
it doesn't matter that you're smarter
than them at that time there's nothing
you can do about it
you could what are you going to
challenge them to a spelling bee it's
not going to help you
you're you're under their control and
that's a horrible horrible feeling
yeah and so i think it's uh you know and
i felt that you know when i was a kid
you know i got bullied just like
everybody everybody gets bullied at a
certain point you know you show up to
high school you're
13 years old i was i was a young
whatever however that works when you
are born that was born in september so
i was a young scrawny kid
and i didn't get bullied to some crazy
extent but
you get picked on you get picked on you
get into little scuffles and you get
thrown around by a kid that's
that reached puberty when he was nine
and he's now you know
six feet 220 and i'm showing up at
school
13 years old weighing a buck 45.
you're gonna get you're gonna get
physically controlled and it's not fun
and so i didn't know how to fight
i was trying to figure it out and there
was no no one knew how to fight back
then unless you were a boxer maybe a
wrestler
um but yeah so definitely this is a huge
piece
helps you with i think i think kids that
know how to fight are going to get a lot
less street fights they're going to do a
lot less stupid things to prove
themselves
because guess what they already have the
essential
primal animalistic characteristic
of physical domination and that goes a
long way
yeah and we talked about this before
back to the girls thing
getting your girls into it
you know how when you get into any kind
of physical situation even if you're in
a crowd and someone starts shoving
someone else not even you
and boom you feel the force of somebody
or someone's just
all like on you or even if someone like
i don't know tackles you or something
like that it's like this kind of imposed
physical situation and when you're into
jiu-jitsu that's
every day so you get used to that real
quick and in fact you get real
comfortable with it
but as a girl you're not trying to like
win fights now you know i know jiu-jitsu
i'm going to try to win fights and beat
up guys that's not really what it's for
for girls
it's more for knowing how to function
knowing where to be where not to be
because man if you don't know you just
simply don't know and also
yeah and also being totally right and
then also being inoculated to the
the physical content when it happens so
you say you can't win i mean not looking
to win fights there's go watch youtube
yeah there's all kinds of videos of
girls just working over guys and i mean
in street fights yeah
there's one in particular where this
girl's just trying to
arm lock just choke just crushing this
kid yeah well the i mean the truth is
if you learn jujitsu if someone knows
jesus someone doesn't
the the chance of the person knowing
jiu-jitsu winning the fight is very very
very high yes even if you're a girl it
still applies to you of course the
girl's at a physical
disadvantage because she's small or weak
or whatever but like i said
jujitsu is just this huge jump in
you know ability as far as fights go and
you know something else
from a pure self-defense perspective
if you a lot of times let's say a girl
is not able to physically let's say
she's a hundred pounds and she's
a guy attacks her that's 200 pounds she
might not be able to
put him to sleep she might not be able
to finish him but she may be able to be
able to
survive fend the guy off for
a minute and 30 seconds instead of two
seconds instead of four seconds
instead of eight seconds so that's what
it takes for someone to hear for someone
to see
so every second counts and if you know
jiu jitsu i guarantee you
uh it's it's really hard to subdue
somebody that knows some jiu jitsu if
you don't know anything you
are gonna have a hard time getting
control of them they're gonna
they're gonna be and even if you're
stronger than them you'll be able to get
a hold of them maybe eventually if
they're a lot smaller a lot weaker than
you but it's gonna be a fight
and a lot of a lot of you know you read
a lot of stories when in self-defense
situations
if the girl puts up a decent fight the
guy is not going to have any of it you
know he's going to realize that he's not
looking for that
he's not looking for a fight he's
looking for something else and so the
fight begins
he backs off so yeah absolutely it
applies for
for girls as well and there's just a
certain level of confidence
yeah you know and i've seen that you
know my son's had a couple little
scuffles
a couple that i've witnessed too where
uh
you know he just was like not trying to
not trying to have a problem
until someone just grabs him and is
obviously gonna do try and do something
to him and then that person's getting
launched you know like hey perfect judo
because you're gonna you know how hard
is it to judo throw somebody that
doesn't know
any judo jiu jitsu it's so easy so you
see a kid fly through the air hit the
ground
you see my son you know just like
there's no guard passing because the
person doesn't even know what the part
is
so it's just straight to mountain yeah
and then once you're in mount the person
has no idea what's happening
and and they're completely controlled
and they're getting put to sleep that's
it
it's as easy as that yeah it's so funny
how you
this is the kind of the part that i
forget actually every once in a while
where how you brought up when you shake
someone's hand you're always thinking
about it or whatever so that's
that's the thing too that's why that's
why it's almost like if you don't know
jujitsu
like or or for real fighting there's not
many out there man there's not many but
even we'll just say if you don't know
jiu-jitsu
you might fall into this trap by
thinking well you know i might you know
you never know he's not on all the time
or he might not be ready for this
or you know i'll surprise him with a
like this punch or something like this
and though they won't give it its due
credit but the thing is when you learn
jiu jitsu bro that's all you're thinking
about
you're like oh take this guy right
here 100 of the time
you you can be laying in your in your
bed with your wife
and she'll be like hey give me a hug and
you're like that's underhook there yes
exactly the whole time so you can't
really
to surprise the guy who knows jiu-jitsu
to surprise him is super hard
like you got to do from behind i don't
know even if you see the front behind
like you know what to do from behind you
know you got to like i don't know hit
him
or something really hard knock him out
one punch behind him and it's really
hard to knock somebody out with one
punch
so yeah but that's so funny because um
that that is how it is
even as like a top like a high level guy
you're still like
it's always on your mind like it's like
you're walking around with this
big powerful like gun or something like
you're like okay who wants to get shot
not that you want to shoot people
specifically but
it's like this radar that's like okay
who wants to get shot kind of thing
because you're just ray it's ready you
know you're just ready to do it
yeah and to me honestly it's so
instinctive
yeah at this point yeah it's just part
of every movement that you make
is thinking about that and you know you
ever had somebody that doesn't know
jiu-jitsu like
maybe you haven't seen someone in a
while i've had that happen i've seen
someone for a while yes
and i mean 20 years so they have no idea
what jiu jitsu is we've got a completely
different path in our lives
and they like grab hold of you as if it
was the old days and you're gonna have a
tussle
yeah yeah it's just a it's just a four
second you know spirit crushing
maneuver of death yeah and you're happy
to do it too you know because as an
adult like you know
i think anywhere past 26 27 years old
it's hard to get away with like getting
into a wrestling match in public or you
know
somewhere outside of the map that's
interesting you might not have known
that
but yeah i don't know i think i speak
for more than more people than just
myself but you
there's a part of your mind that kind of
helps it it happens just with your
friend you know or something like that
just so you can do it of course always
on your mind always hoping for
a scrap you know what ironically back to
the part where we're all saying um it's
kind of hard to surprise
the jujitsu guy ironically the easiest
time to surprise the jiu jitsu guy
is on the mat if you're another jiu
jitsu guy what you do is you play like
oh we're just going light right now
and then you go hard you know so you
can't really surprise them in the
like in public you gotta like you gotta
learn jiu-jitsu go on the mat
roll with them make them think you're
not rolling hard then surprisingly and
you know i think that's part of it is
you become more aware we're just talking
what you've been talking about the past
couple minutes
is awareness and when you have jujitsu
in your brain
then and it's true with boxing too and
muay thai
when you have that stuff in your brain
then
you can't help but be aware of what's
happening around you because it's in
there it's like knowing that the color
of the table is brown like you
you know what that person's body
position is you're looking and seeing
that their stance is off balance you're
seeing
an underhook exposed you know so you
can't help you can't take it away so
your awareness increases you also
are aware of what problems can occur
really quickly so if you start
you know if you're a girl and you say oh
wait a second
now i'm back into a corner where i can't
get out i don't like this feeling
it becomes it increases your awareness
as a human it makes you more aware of
your surroundings so
there's so many benefits yeah it's kind
of ridiculous
yeah you kind of have almost like one
level up from that
awareness that you're talking about
because like how you're saying it's part
of that
even if you don't know how to fight it's
still kind of on your mind you know you
like all guys have that kind of sort of
evaluation especially if the guy's close
to your
close to you yeah who you are you know
whether the age size whatever
whatever the scenario even like if
you're a scholar and no one else is
scholar then another scholar walks in
ooh this evaluation you know so that's
how it is naturally see how smart this
guy is
yeah yeah so oh so as a guy just
naturally you're gonna have even more
it's like you know what the color of
brown is or whatever
but just instinctually you're always
looking for brown
that's kind of what it's like so now you
when you're doing these evaluations that
are gonna happen anyway
your jujitsu mind is right there at the
front
ready the whole time yeah indigenous
thing
training people but that's not to be
confused with like you're aggressive and
want to fight that's the weird thing
it's like you don't want to
actually fight with people because you
don't feel the need to like oh i
i don't know that's where this whole
conversation started off
and also now you not feel like you need
to prove anything but i literally i'm
like oh do i really want to get a fight
with this guy i'm gonna get my knuckles
you know right i'm probably gonna rip my
t-shirt this guy's gonna grab is this
really no
i i fight every single day
i don't need i don't i don't care about
this guy
this is a two second thing where i gotta
scuff up my knee
on the pavement and he's probably gonna
rip my sh my shirt
and that's going to be a pain and i got
to deal with the cops if they show up
it's just a big pain
whereas if you don't fight and you have
that opportunity maybe you've got the
thing inside you
you don't know right the payoff of the
fight right if you don't know or if
you're just insecure or whatever the
payoff of the fight and hopefully
winning
is bigger than all the detriments that
you have i used to tell my platoon guys
um when we were overseas before the war
started and you know so guys are
overseas what are you doing you're
drinking you're out in bars you're
causing problems or whatever and i you
know before you go out i'll be like hey
guys if you feel like fighting tonight
come find me because if you want to
fight come find me and
it'll be all be good you know you know
we'll we'll fight and
it's all good you won't get in trouble
you won't get arrested you won't get
hurt it's all good oh you'll get in
trouble
you get in trouble for sure you're not
getting in trouble with the law though
you know what i mean you're not going to
get that kind of trouble you're getting
a little trouble in your situation and
you're in your positioning
is going to be troublesome so yeah it's
better to fight amongst yourself than to
fight against the outsiders who are
going to sue you
pull a knife out and stab you in the
throat whatever
right yeah don't do that stay out of the
street fights
not worth it you know all right i agree
with it too though
you said you agree that it is the
stabilizer
it is because if you don't know you
don't even know how much you don't know
it's funny because we get a lot of
people that have started training jiu
jitsu
good move yes but they but they'll come
on twitter
or on on the facebook and and say
you know um hey i started training jiu
jitsu oh my god
i can't believe i i need to train this
all the time i can't believe i got
control
they always say how humiliating and
sometimes they say humbling
but sometimes i think even when they say
humbling they actually mean humiliating
because they you that's the weird thing
when you're walking around on the earth
without the knowledge you think you look
at other people you think you know what
this guy knows jiu-jitsu i heard this
guy knows it doesn't matter
i'm strong i'm athletic i'll just hit
him in the neck or even even you know
i'm just strong enough he's not gonna
get my how is he gonna get my arm over
there
yeah it's not gonna work i'll just pull
my arm back right and you get on the mat
you go oh my lord i have no control over
the situation
this guy is effortlessly making me
submit over and over and over again
and that's when the reality hits the
reality hits doesn't end on the first
time you tap because on the first time
you tap you go
oh i'm gonna i'll just i won't do that
single movement again i won't stick my
head over there okay
so then you get your arm locked yeah and
then you get your foot locked and then
you get your knee locked and you get
commute and then you get
guillotined again you get rid of so you
always just lose lose lose lose lose
lose
lose and then you go after usually for
me it's like three to five times with
somebody that's never trained jiu jitsu
before
three to five times before they realize
like oh that i will never
because you know when you tap a guy once
that's never trained before and he comes
at you so hard
in his mind he thinks oh this time i'm
gonna get him and they don't even come
close they don't even realize
so yeah get on the mat man and learn
learn the jiu jitsu